PROFESSOR: In Chapter 3, we will
study epidemiological models,
which describe the
spread of an infection
and then the recovery from
that infection in a population.
And the traditional
epidemiological models
that we will study
for populations,
and also adapt to
indoor spaces, involve
keeping track of compartments
or subgroups of populations,
such as the number of
susceptible people,
the number of infected,
exposed, and recovered.
So for example,
an infected person
can expose a
susceptible, and then
the exposed person can
themselves become infected,
or they may eventually recover.
And there are various rates
for these different processes.
And this leads to a set
of nonlinear differential
equations that describe the
evolution and growth, and then
ultimately decay,
of an epidemic.